hello and welcome to 30 playing Brooklyn
2003 well what a huge reading mismatch
and I'm on early and somehow not that
many titled players around so i got the
russell demo again with the capture and
diet III i had exactly the same thing I
just two or three games ago maybe we
repeat this game he hasn't played a 3
which is good for him
then I lost xod mins oh yeah then those
pawns are not weak on c6 and c5
I wonder if this F cakes FYI yeah that I
had in the earlier game okay No so I'm
going to then go for the the Pont roller
that will be extremely dangerous for
white heat he has he takes he needs some
time until they have something going in
the center
and white wine each outer drive like
maybe 92 and see 3d form here may I
should have played you for a while it
was some conveniently possible it's so
pretty okay but still okay that doesn't
work deformed still on that
it's not super convincing energy form
this is the ideas uk7 and then bring the
book over so okay maybe have to invest
this time that's also not bad it just
stops any business there and now see if
we can switch to the other side with 24
stuff well let's do it
I just recognized I said before is going
to be tricky for me and the book is
queen bee three queen bee free stuff is
to handing this quite well
who f6 mmm
maybe force is always on the agenda
I don't really see anything good an
amazing okay here I've probably have to
go back there okay 47 now that is dead
it is defending this really really well
what is he doing now I mean he cannot
move the rooks Queen somewhere but then
Mike might come back in to be sure the
age for two to three years probably on
the cards I know is that really
threatens much to be honest that Bishop
coming
[Music]
now let's get split up a bit passive now
if he has to like resides why why to
screen f2 I mean okay in the computer
lost my position with and I kind of
thought that this might be the right one
because he is a bit bit tied down he
cannot really move all that much but
still many defendant is really well that
that position that position really
sucked but he defended as well many am I
should probably go G 4 I underestimated
this a little bit in this is stopping
things for quite a while and yeah it is
not bad or queen bee six more strongly I
just focus on that pawn hmm nope that
was bad chant here this is kind of good
yeah it's nothing nothing special and is
keeping things protected it has look be
told
[Music]
the end there that doesn't threaten much
I mean okay Quinn between f2 and then g5
blackest black seems to win according to
the engine but not such a super clear
thing can a bishop age 40 lame simply
too much pressure yeah it's probably too
much pressure yeah but well defended by
by Brooklyn 2003 okay thanks for
watching